intentar asfixiar económicamente a rusia
esa ha sido la principal respuesta de
occidente por la guerra el primer golpe
llevó a las pocas horas de que comenzó
la invasión a ucrania cuando el consejo
europeo congeló los activos y prohibió
las visas del primer grupo de personas
cercanas al kremlin estados unidos
prohibió la venta de insumos
tecnológicos a rusia las siguientes
sanciones fueron directamente contra el
presidente vladimir putin y su canciller
sérguei lávrov
encantado de ser alcalde después de una
conversación telefónica entre el
presidente wyden y la presidenta de la
comisión europea von der leyen y en
consonancia con la decisión de nuestros
aliados europeos eeuu y unir a ellos
para sancionar al presidente putin y el
ministro de relaciones exteriores
larroque y a miembros del equipo de
seguridad nacional rusa
si tan solo la unión europea ha
sancionado a un centenar de entidades y
a más de 1200 personas incluidas putin y
lávrov
351 parlamentarios y más de 30 oligarcas
además el transporte también se ha
limitado el bloque restringió sus vías
terrestres su espacio aéreo y sus
puertos para los rusos con contadas
excepciones para quienes llevan
materiales humanista y corto la difusión
de cinco medios estatales incluyendo
sputnik bruselas y washington también
prohibieron la importación de materias
primas como el oro y el hierro y al
corazón de la economía lo atacaron
limitando las transacciones con el banco
ruso central el golpe más fuerte fue la
exclusión del sistema swift lo que
desconectó los bancos rusos del sistema
financiero internacional se están
acercando de delicioso
el primer ministro y yo discutimos el
tema teniendo en cuenta que las
sanciones que la comunidad occidental o
como yo la llamó el imperio de mentiras
está intentando implementar en contra de
nuestro país
eeuu fue un paso más allá y cortó el gas
natural una movida que europa aún está
lejos de hacer por su alta dependencia
putin comenzó a hablar de países no
amistosos ya ellos les puso una nueva
cláusula pagar en rublos todo el gas que
comprarán de rusia una medida por la que
ya se ha acortado el suministro de
naciones europeas como polonia bulgaria
y finlandia además moscú también
prohibió la entrada a su territorio a
cientos de personas de todo el mundo
incluyendo a byte en parlamentarios
británicos japoneses entre otros luego
llegó la decisión más difícil para la
unión europea cortar el crudo la
decisión se tomó con fuertes divisiones
hungría república checa y eslovaquia
lograron que no se frenará su
importación por oleoductos dada su alta
dependencia
los europeos acusaron a rusia de usar la
energía como un arma de guerra
y hay que decirlo la situación está
empeorando en la medida en que los
anuncios sobre el uso de gas y petróleo
como armas ahora se están haciendo
realidad en varios lugares
stein jr
en medio de la guerra 300 compañías ya
salieron de rusia y cerca de 700
redujeron considerablemente sus
operaciones entre ellas están adidas
nike disney netflix spotify starbucks la
petrolera shell cocacola entre otras los
resultados de las múltiples presiones
económicas son un pib ruso que podría
caer un 11,2 por ciento este año según
la proyección del banco mundial y una
inflación en la mayoría de los países
occidentales que ha subido los precios a
niveles históricos